sí muy buenos días pues efectivamente no
veremos hagan bernal en estos
maravillosos parajes de los alpes lo que
dijo de víveres por quien fue quien
anunció el retiro de bernal y que es el
director del equipo de negocios que lo
hicieron sobre todo para los mejores
intereses de gana bernal él viene
quejándose de unos problemas en las
lumbares lo cual lo hizo del ya de por
sí pues a retirarse del criterio define
y en la etapa de ayer lo vimos que hacía
estiramientos de esta parte de su
espalda además de tener también un dolor
en una rodilla así que esa zona las
razones se hagan bernal por su parte
también dio a conocer en un comunicado
pues que no era ésta la manera como él
esperaba terminar este tour o 2020 pero
pues a que entendía bien dadas las
circunstancias porque efectivamente
desde el domingo en el con colombia
donde se vio que ya él no tenía piernas
pues a justamente el día de hoy con esta
etapa tan fuerte seguramente era
imposible incluso que llegara en los
tiempos para continuar aún dentro del
número de corredores